bonsoir florian philippot le vice
président du front national est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
présent à ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec l' agence france-presse
trois grandes questions comme chaque
semaine une question par partie première
question est ce que vous êtes de mauvais
perdants dans les régions en multipliant
on l'a vu à les incidents lors des
nouvelles assemblées régionales alors
que l'emploi semble-t-il ouvre la voie à
une collaboration entre l'exécutif et
les présidents de droite
on l'a vu aujourd'hui à matignon comme à
l'élysée deuxième question florian
philippot est ce que vous avez perdu
votre meilleur ennemi
avec le départ de christiane taubira et
vous direz à big eyes à metz si vous
êtes sûr de pouvoir revendiquer une
victoire idéologique avec la déchéance
de nationalité qui est de plus en plus
contesté à à gauche au parti socialiste
mais également on le voit à droite
enfin troisième question le front
national va-t-il changer de ligne
économique un virage libéral voire pro
euros ce serait aller un peu loin tous
les cas c'est ce qui sera décidé ce
week-end lors d'un séminaire que réunit
votre parti et vous répondrais sur ce
sujet à guillaume daudin de l' agence
france presse mais avant de vous poser
la première question sur les régions
donc présente aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec
manuel valls et françois hollande votre
réaction au vote unanime des élus
européens à strasbourg contre la levée
de votre immunité parlementaire
le procès donc voulu par le qatar contre
vous n'aura pas lieu vous maintenez que
cet état du golfe finance le terrorisme
va en tout cas il l'a financé il
faudrait savoir si le finance toujours
il ya des choses manifestement
extrêmement louche dans l'entourage de
ce pays et y compris de l'arabie
saoudite
ce n'est pas à moi de le dire mais je
suis heureux que la liberté d'expression
et de critique d'un élu d'un
parlementaire et même d'un citoyen en
général dans une démocratie comme la
france ait pu être préservée je trouve
je vous le dis très clairement et
réaffirmée par le parlement européen
oui mais je le trouve honteux que la
france l'état français par la signature
mais mme taubira qui avait transmis
cette demande de levée d'immunité
admission ça ne voulait pas vraiment
d'illusions
un ministre a toujours la liberté de ne
pas signer et que là que la lave et mars
mais la procédure exactement que la
tendance
et puis accepter cette procédure
judiciaire qui est incompréhensible à la
plupart des autres pays européens est
simplement dans la plupart les autres
démocraties en dit long sur notre état
de soumission par rapport au qatar alors
je serai bien il y aura pas trop
sévèrement
donc vous vous maintenez vos propos mais
le qatar dit que c'est de la diffamation
on peut le dire ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils
souffrent la critique et surtout qu'il
change de politique
le qatar est une infâme dictature qui ne
respectent pas les femmes qui ne
respectent pas les minorités qui a un
comportement extrêmement louche
vis-à-vis du fondamentalisme islamiste
c'est une évidence et c'est bien celui
là au lieu de critiquer et d'intimider
doit se réformer en profondeur ou doit
disparaître de nos relations
diplomatiques
en tout cas on n'en prend pas le chemin
puisque manuel valls a gambergé avec la
france soit moins soumise et que les
dirigeants français soient moins soumis
à ce confetti à ce petit pays et vous
parlez d'une soumission manuel valls lui
a dit récemment c'était il ya quelques
mois il a dit sa conviction il ne doute
pas que le qatar lutte contre le
terrorisme oui il faro moi je le ramène
au livre de vos confrères monsieur péan
mêmes ratinier à d'autres enquêtes
rapport écrit par les services français
américains et qui sont beaucoup plus
dubitatif et surtout au delà même du
financement du terrorisme et où l'on
mettra un point d'interrogation à
leucate est rare mettez un point je ne
sais d'ailleurs il ya eu du financement
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas en tout cas
sur le reste il faudrait et j'ai demandé
une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
en y intégrant le front national via par
exemple les députés européens sur les
financements du qatar dans notre pays
financement prise de participation dans
les grandes entreprises stratégie on va
pas lui reprocher c'est mal si j'ai rien
à voir 6 6 entre dénoncé le financement
du terrorisme
l'activité économique en france korian
philippe ans et massifs les prises de
participation dans des entreprises
stratégiques
c'est pas le premier indicateur ses
trains de la france comment la france
peut-elle accepter cela les financements
religieux financement de certaines
mosquées
qu'est ce qui s'y passe qu'est ce qui
s'y dit et puis évidemment les liens
entre le qatar et le personnel politique
institutionnelle et économique français
mais est-ce que tout est clair dans
cette affaire est ce que toi pourquoi
l'ensemble des dirigeants
gouvernementaux français sont ils à plat
ventre devant le qatar dès qu'on parle
de ce pays que se passe-t-il pourquoi
point d'interrogation
j'aimerais qu'on éclaircisse la question
je trouve
vous dire jouer vous et la russie pucci
gens vous dira on déjà on ne peut pas
comparer les pays nous ne sommes pas aux
responsabilités moi je suis tout à fait
capable d'avoir un langage extrêmement
critique sur la rice sur la russie si
vous le souhaitez je dis simplement que
la france doit rééquilibrer ses
relations internationales ne soient pas
soumises à washington c'est pour cela
que nous souhaitons un vrai qu'il ya
d'orage m'honore notamment vers la
russie mais pas que vous avez d'autres
monarchies du golfe dans le viseur par
le qatar je pense qu'il ya deux pays qui
sont reconnus comme étant louche
vis-à-vis du fondamentalisme c'est le
qatar et l'arabie saoudite avec deux
pays ont fait beaucoup de pays qui sont
d'infâmes dictature et sur lesquels on
n'entend jamais recruté par exemple avec
la rabine on le faisait on en aurait on
voit quand même nos ministres à plat
ventre devant l'émir du qatar devant le
roi d'arabie saoudite on ne comprend pas
pourquoi alors que parfois c'est mon
travail à des contrats aidés contrat
mais ils ont une ville et j'en oublie
leur moral
ils sont maintenant beaucoup plus
pointilleux vis-à-vis d'autres pays qui
ne sont pas des démocraties parfaite
c'est moins compliqué mais qui ne sont
pas les dictatures aussi infâme que ces
deux pays est-ce qu'il faut renoncer aux
contrats commerciaux alors avec le qatar
et l'arabie saoudite
à quand il engage la france sur sa
parole sur sa politique étrangère oui
s'il s'agit d'acheter notre diplomatique
des dollars ou des pétrodollars
certainement pas finir la france doit
avoir une parole libre une diplomatie
libre s il s'agit d'entreprises
stratégiques que ce soit le qatar ou un
autre pays je souhaite qu'on fasse
valoir le patriotisme économique de
toute façon florian philippot la
question se pose aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est le sujet de la réunion de rome
avec une cinquantaine d'états de
l'ouverture d'un troisième front contre
le groupe etat islamique en libye est ce
que vous y soyez favorable c'est-à-dire
aller réparer à les combattre la
progression à l'air et à ray kay après
l'éclairage et les candidats se situer
un sanctuaire
oui oui c'est à dire aller réparer les
conséquences de l'intervention
désastreuse de monsieur sarkozy et de sa
muse bernard henri lévy en 2011 que le
front national était le seul à avoir des
morts c'est dans la classe politique sur
celle de méditation les généraux quand
même faut quand même ramené toujours les
choses pour sinon comprend rien d'accord
on en est là qui a détruit l'état libyen
c'est sarkozy qui a mis à la place les
djihadistes et aujourd'hui le verrou
vers l'europe
c'est aussi la politique de sarkozy
soutenue par le ps est vrai qu'on fait
aujourd'hui il faut ya déjà peut-être
des frappes oui si le fruit même si on
n'a pas le choix si on n'a pas le choix
face aux fauves où on ira donc réparé et
encore une fois ce qu'on a fait nous
mêmes
et si on n'a pas le choix je veux pas
pour la politique du pire certainement
pas d'intervention sol peut-être des
frappes
il faudra qu'on en discute qu'on en
débatte tous et peut-être qu'on se pose
la question d'un deuxième porte avions
français
moi je suis très favorable à ce que nous
ayons deux porte-avions et on voit que
dans cette affaire ça pourrait être
extrêmement utile une grande puissance
une grande puissance diplomatique et
militaire comme la france devrait avoir
deux porte avions
par ailleurs ce serait un investissement
extrêmement rentable ça ferait
travailler nos chantiers ce après
travailler nos ingénieurs nos ouvriers
et ça permettrait d'aller vers
l'innovation je pense qu'il ya que des
avantages est ce que vous craignez que
les terroristes dissimule certains des
leurs parmi les migrants qui quittent on
le sait en masse les côtes libyennes
ben je le crains d'autant plus que nous
le nous prévenons sur ce sujet là depuis
des mois et des mois et même bien avant
les attentats du 13 novembre alors à
l'époque on nous disait qu'on fantasme
et qu'on veut jouer sur les peurs qui
ont surfé chaussures je ne sais quoi
il se trouve que parmi les les kamikazes
du 13 novembre il y avait des en
infiltré dans la route des migrants donc
nous avions raison il faut arrêter et
c'est de ce flux de migrants faut que la
france retrouve des frontières
nationales et qu'elle arrête à l'heure
et politique de la passoire quête
schengen vous avez vu ce qui se passe en
suède le pays a assuré qu'il allait
renvoyer 50% des migrants qui sont
arrivés sur son sol en un an
ça fait quand même 80 mille réfugiés la
moitié de ceux qui sont venus donc les
renvoyer mais manchester est ce que
c'est un modèle à suivre avant d'arrêter
d'en faire venir d'autres de façon il va
falloir renvoyer ceux qui sont là le but
n'est pas le renvoi pour le renvoi il
trouve qu'il ya des gens qui sont
arrivés en masse où il va falloir
notamment parce qu'ils sont entrés en
clandestinité ou parce qu'on estime que
le système d'asile est saturé il va
falloir vérifier qu'ils sont là à 50%
n'auront pas droit à l'asile ou qu'on
sait que c'est une proportion qui fixez
votre équitable en france ont le droit à
la ville c'est un tiers je crois des
demandeurs d'asile donc 50 % la suède
reste extrêmement généreuse c'est un
exemple qui va d'ailleurs
incompréhensible vu les drames qu'a
connue ce pays
on l'a su qu'ils avaient été cachés plus
ou moins par les autorités par la police
et les médias notamment je parle
d'agression sexuelle de valeur leur
masse comme parler du drame
oui ce sont des drames alors il ya et je
voulais vous parler d'un la dame
attendait sur ce sujet là et en ce
moment continue s'avère il avait un
petit peu arrêté avant les régionales
pendant deux trois semaines
nouveau on voit des migrants arrivés
dans les villages les communes les
villes françaises
j'ai des exemples aujourd'hui un jardin
on apprend que les migrants vont arriver
un peu partout et sans l'avis la
consultation des habitants des
populations et souvent même des mères
vous parlez de draveil ou sur l'ailé
politique n'est pas viable
aller à parler notre âme les naufrages
inde migrants en mer egée sont
pratiquement 1 survient plus de 300
enfants sont morts une quatre derniers
mois
que dites vous pour rompre avec cette
indifférence quasi générale qu'ils il
pas sûr que les l'indifférence je pense
que la soeur parle pas très peu de temps
mais un peu politique on peut on peut
faire couler des larmes de crocodile est
considéré qu'il faut donc accueilli en
règle menée par leurs différents mais
personne n'est indifférent à cela mais
on peut qu'elle il ya deux solutions
soit on dit il faut donc accueillir tout
le monde par grandeur d'âme par
générosité mais en réalité vous allez
susciter des flux de plus en plus
important et donc vous aurez de plus en
plus de noyade ou deux personnes qui se
retrouveront et tout fait dans des
camions ou je ne sais quoi
soit vous dites il faut qu'il ya des
camps là bas sur place les camps de
réfugiés
quitte à ce qu'on finance davantage
l'onu le hcfc mais c'est le plan de
l'europe oui non mais non le plan de
l'europe c'est d'en faire venir quatre
millions en europe cette année en
relation deux autres spots comme on dit
ne te le plan de la numéro elle s'est
pas laissé là-bas merkel en lacets venir
leur marque et qu'elle avait réalisé un
petit peu sur la position de son
jugement je regarde moi des chiffres
chaque semaine il en arrivait énormément
encore en allemagne
or il n'ya plus de frontières au sein de
l'union européenne dont ils peuvent
venir en france qu'ils soient là bas et
puis qu'on re stabilise la région bien
sûr par une action diplomatique
intelligente contre l'état islamique on
n'en prend pas tout à fait le chemin
alors dans l'actualité et là je reviens
à la question du départ faire un filippo
il y a donc les présidents de région
aujourd'hui à matignon et à l'elysée
pour une action commune pour l'emploi à
travers la formation donc manuel valls
n'exclut pas d'ailleurs d'accorder de
nouveaux pouvoirs en ce sens aux
exécutifs
nous avons rencontré l'ensemble des
présidents de région et je me suis
exprimé juste avant de venir ici à
l'assemblée nationale avec le président
des régions de france
ce philippe richert sur le fait que nous
étions en train d'élaborer pour les
prochains jours pour les prochaines
semaines un document conjoint qui donne
davantage de respect
sabilité aux régions et dans le cadre
des lois actuelles c'est-à-dire de la
luano devoir s'il faut aller plus loin
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle législation
qui permette aux régions d'assumer et
d'assurer pleinement leurs
responsabilités dans le domaine du
développement économique de la formation
de l'accompagnement des chômeurs et de
l'apprentissage et j'ai dis encore une
fois que nous devions être à l'écouté de
l'ensemble des régions car au delà des
couleurs politiques
nous avions une responsabilité c'est de
tout faire pour le chômage alors que
pensez vous de cette main tendue de deux
côtés d'ailleurs ses responsabilités
partagées ça va dans le bon sens c'est
une main tendue c'est une valse
permanente
enfin son jeu de moder congo et ils sont
si vous voulez monsieur richard
puisqu'il en parle c'est le président du
sénat les élus ou je reprenne que je
préside le principal groupe d'opposition
en alsace champagne-ardennes lorraine
sur ichat dans saint-roch son discours
d'investiture en quelque sorte a déclaré
sa flamme à manuel valls
donc ils considèrent que le parti
socialiste fait partie de sa majorité et
la marre de voir comment ça se passe il
ya aucune différence
on a passé six heures à voter lors de la
dernière session pas une fois où
peut-être une fois il s'est abstenu et
pas une fois le groupe de gauche soit
disant d'opposition a voté contre ou c
ou a émis une proposition fait un
amendement ou quoi que ce soit donc
évidemment qu'ils sont ensemble ils
partagent tous non mais quand même fait
élire ensemble la cause commune c'est
l'emploi oui enfin le désastre commun
surtout on sort de 30 ans de cogestion
ump s ou rps aujourd'hui dans les
régions et au niveau national surtout on
voit que le chômage n'a jamais été aussi
élevé la pauvreté aussi donc lors leur
désastre est commun alors c'est pourquoi
je voudrais favorable à tout nouveau
transfert de compétences de toutes
façons d'abord toute nouvelle
décentralisation
je reprends la ce que disait philippe
séguin le regretter quand il était
président de la cour des comptes
la décentralisation est structurellement
coûteuse alors c'est pour ça que vous
êtes nous le mur dans jordi l'aise j'ai
lu ça coûte cher c'est pour ça que vous
avez l'air d'être des mauvais perdants
là dans tous les conseils à des
invectives des incidents et intel
deux élus du front national qui traitent
les autres de niakoués par exemple il
s'est traité lui même en disant on n'est
pas des bons il s'est traité lui-même il
demandait à ce que les oreilles la
possible et le mot procédure le monde
régi l'éviter il aurait pu éviter le
maurupt mais c'est bien sûr mais si vous
voulez moi je suis à la tête et tu lis
dans nos groupes ça se passe comme cela
je suis à la tête d'un groupe
extrêmement responsable j'ai fait voter
la dernière fois deux amendements à
l'unanimité comme on a dans mon
assemblée
j'ai fait par exemple le traduire en
langage des signes les séances du
conseil régional c'est nous qui l'avons
proposé ça a été rude dans votre
programme l'unanimité pas le grand
barouf le mot avait été dit mais on est
leur mari en bar ouf
non c'est pas le grand barouf là on est
là on est là vigilant pour faire
respecter nos engagements vis-à-vis de
nos sept millions d'électeurs et comptez
pas sur nous pour être le des
paillassons comme le parti socialiste
vis-à-vis de l'ump où l'ump vis-à-vis du
parti socialiste selon qui est qui et
qui l'opposition la majorité
nous sommes là intransigeant et en même
temps constructif par exemple le
président henri certes un dans une
conseil régional a donné sans
consultation aux 169 élus des iphone si
soyez du coût de 700 euros plus
l'abonnement à tous les élus pas vous
l'avais gardé
non nous nos 46 élus on est là on les a
rendus et les soldats donner aussi des
détails noirs il a donné des ipad va
vous l'avais gardé comme dans toutes les
régions de france mais il avoue l'avait
gardé à la c'est un instrument travail
parce que les documents ne sont plus
maintenant mais les documents de son
prix imprimer un document ne sont plus
imprimer donc nous avons l'instrument de
travail
ok mais vous avez gardé à vous avez
rendu l'autre enfin je vous devriez
apprécier monsieur grossiord qu'on est
rendu l'iphone on est les seuls à
l'avoir fait bon voilà on est les seuls
à avoir fait écouter 700 euros fait
l'addition 700 euros x 169 plus les
abonnements mensuels donc libéré par
ailleurs j'aurais aimé puisque vous
parlez de la tablette j'aurais
effectivement qu'elles soient de
fabrication française avec mais si on
avait été consulté on aura tout le dire
on n'a même pas été consultés bon allez
on parle toujours de l'emploi avec
l'idée qu'ils progressent au
gouvernement pour vous dire gaspillage
gaspillage on l'a dit dans nos campagnes
les dévoyer la première décision qu'ils
prennent c'est de dilapider l'argent
public
d'accord dans l'exemple philippe richert
et lui se fait de réaliser cinq cent
mille euros d'économies tout ça comment
avec la dématérialisation que vous
évoquez on verra alors l'idée progresse
par ailleurs et sans sur l'emploi d'une
dégressivité des allocations chômage
je fasse d'abord au déficit abyssal de
l'assedic l'idée avait été lancée ici
même à votre place la part le secrétaire
d'état chargé des relations avec le
parlement et jean marie le guen on
écoute autant il est extrêmement
difficile de diminuer les aides aux
chômeurs une période où le chômage est
encore très élevé et en même temps c'est
bien que à la fois un peu pour des
raisons financières dont vous parliez
mais aussi pour mobiliser plus de moyens
sur la formation des chômeurs il est
assez vraisemblable qu'il faut un petit
peu changé les paramètres de notre
assurance chômage alors changer les
paramètres aller jusqu'à la dégressivité
des allocations serre qu'ils renoncent
ont-ils jamais tentée d'ailleurs il
renonce à lutter contre le chômage donc
ils vont lutter contre les chômeurs bon
cette dégressivité elle a existé en
france entre 1900 et 2000 the man with
les arguments c'est leur métier dans le
paquet sur la formation et les traîtres
plus incitatif même si ça n'avait pas
fonctionné
vraiment une expérience qui a duré 10
ans 92 2001 en france ça n'a eu aucun
effet ça a été éprouvée par des études
je crois de l'insee qui ont démontré que
ça n'avait pas eu d'impact sur l'endroit
où vous êtes pour le gélat tu qu un nom
mais on est nous pour une vraie
politique de l'emploi on pense pas qu'il
faille taper sur les chômeurs on pense
pas que la solution ce soit de lutter
contre les chômeurs mais de lutter
contre le chômage où il ya des fraudeurs
mais il faut lutter de manière générale
beaucoup plus activement contre la
fraude c'est une évidence mais moi je ne
sépare le bon grain de l'ivraie jeux
permettent tout le monde dans le même
sac parce que l'immense majorité des
chômeurs s'ils n'ont pas de boulot c'est
simplement qu'à pas de boulot et qu'ils
on cherche et quand il ya 6 millions
le quasiment de chômeurs aujourd'hui en
france c'est parce que la situation est
terrible que notre pays est largement
désindustrialisé qu'à passer en
investissements dans l'innovation cas
pas si l'on tient aux pme/tpe assedic
vous incitez les syndicats à faire
barrage à la fois au gouvernement et au
medef qui prône également cette meuf
jeudi le gouvernement doivent enlever
ses oeillères et le idéologique et
changer complètement de politique pour
lutter pour l'emploi notamment en
sortant des dogmes européen qui nous
désindustrialise massivement alors qui
nous empêchent dede les petits qui nous
empêche de faire du patriotisme
économique et qui nous plombe est un
personnage qui refait parler de soleil
et terrorisé on a tout essayé contre le
show
vaz moi je suis obligé de dire on n'a
rien essayé contre le chômage on tourne
en rond sur des mesures est toujours les
mêmes pour essayer de baisser les
statistiques du chômage depuis 25 ans ça
ne fonctionne pas mais il continue parce
qu'il ya des sujets qu'ils ne peuvent
pas l'aborder par idéologie on reviendra
dans la dernière interview accordée à
guillaume daudin sur le programme
économique du front national qui est en
débat par ailleurs je le disais tout à
l'heure il ya un personnage qui revient
dans l'actualité c'est bernard tapie en
fait jamais été très loin de l'actualité
en tous les cas il est saisi l'a dit
récemment dans une interview au jdd par
une ambition politique
il ad ailleurs dit qu'il voulait lui
interdire le chômage des jeunes mais
dans le fait que le travail ait pas
pensé quand le 'financial times'
interdire le chômage dans le 'financial
times'
bernard tapie se voit en arbitre de la
prochaine présidentielle a même dit il
de séduire une partie de votre électorat
et il dit à 5 ou 6%
c'est moi qui déterminerait le vainqueur
du second tu vois ce qu'il est une
menace pour vos jeux c'est là que
bernard tapie avait encore des velléités
l'arbitrage après ce qui lui était
arrivé on est obligé de commenter ou on
passe à autre chose
on peut passer à autre chose c'est votre
commentaire s'ils savaient tenir à le
voir au théâtre à l'elysée raul castro a
été reçu avec les honneurs la france
est-elle raison de soutenir l'évolution
même très lentes on peut le dire de
l'île communiste et de demander avec
force la levée de l'embargo américain
oui il a raison de demander la levée de
cet embargo il faut jamais pénalisé les
populations comme on l'a fait par
exemple en irak c'était terrible qu'on
évolue je m'en félicite il faut toujours
il faut dialoguer avec les clés avec les
états la difficulté c'est qu'on le fait
toujours après le coup de sifflet
américain une fois qu'on a eu
l'autorisation au fait qu'elle a sur
cuba ça sert à réchauffer d'abord avec
les états unis donc la france y va on de
mêmes choses sur l'iran on a perdu
beaucoup de contrats parce qu'on avait
interdiction américaine d'y aller une
fois que les etats unis se sont
rapprochés de l'iran il ya eu garneau si
on se rapproche
l'accord est un peu dommage nucléaire et
est international et donc notamment
arraché par la france un surveillant oui
bien sûr mais bon c'est pas suivi ce
n'est pas un alignement américain moi je
regrette un peu
le général de gaulle sur une chine dans
les airs au début des années 60 il avait
une position audacieuse il avait montré
la voie en reconnaissant la pluie
populaire aujourd'hui on est suivi cette
voie là les etats-unis disent vous
pouvez y aller donc on y va et pendant
ce temps là on perd beaucoup de contrats
on perd beaucoup d'influx ans on perd
beaucoup de rayonnement est ce que vous
appelez à l'évacuation par la force du
site du futur aéroport de notre dame des
landes près de nantes
nous sommes défavorables à cet
investissement cet aéroport
non pas qu'on est défavorable aux
infrastructures générales au contraire
mais pour le coup on avait fait une
étude locale sur cet aéroport qui ne
nous semble pas qui nous a jamais semblé
indispensable ni utile après gérer la
situation locale
il va respecter la loi comme des
questions laurent ruquier a déclaré dans
le supplément de leur village ma
dernière sur la télé pourquoi décédé -
bernard tapie ruquier bah oui mais lui
laurent ruquier s'adresse directement à
vous est offert par louis dionne quart
d'heure people bah écoute et voilà je si
le front national parce je prends mes
cliques et mes claques et je me tire et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette prise
de position
on lui dira bye bye olivier rey buybuy
vous n'avez pas le retenir ou nouveau
die le bail ne pas mais pour qui se
prend-il jambe et lui dire faux
dégonfler scala ou par une petite
épinglé book une petite épargne c'est
souvent ça fait du bien bon alors
deuxième partie des proches partout à la
deuxième question que va vous poser
mille kms de public sénat dans un sens
que vous avez perdu votre meilleur et
demi avec christiane taubira on verra
quel parti en fait la déchéance de
nationalité trouve de nouveaux opposants
les députés ps qui rechignait demande
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même de nouvelles
garanties pour ne pas créer des
apatrides et puis également les députés
les républicains doute de plus en plus
un peu à l'instar d'alain juppé qui
affirme que c'est un texte complètement
inutile
mais écoutons d'abord christiane taubira
quelques jours à new york 1 devant des
étudiants qui met son souffle oratoire
vous allez nous dire si vous y êtes
sensibles au service de la défense des
libertés et de l'égalité
il faut que les citoyens soient égaux
entre eux égaux devant le savoir
igo dans l'accès aux droits égaux dans
l'accès aux soins égaux entre eux
l'égalité n'est pas un slogan l'égalité
est un défi quotidienne la puissance
publique est donc indispensable et elle
a des devoirs elle allait devoir qu'elle
doit assumer et en particulier à
l'époque où nous vivons l'époque où nous
vivons est une époque de grands
désordres de grands chaos dans le monde
et assurer l'égalité dans un lieu
suppose ne pas s'accommoder des
inégalités et des injustices y compris
dans des lieux lointains mais tms nous a
rejoint vincent mutel
on a envie de connaître évidemment les
réactions notre de neutralité vous
pouvez interroger
on parle évidemment du fougeray une
question de forme elle va vous manquer
christiane taubira non ne nous manqueras
pas et elle ne manquera pas je le crois
aux français pas d'après d'ailleurs on
l'a vu dans les premiers sondages ils
sont plus de 80 % à approuver sa
démission
je le comprends parce que même taubira
je juge la ministre de la justice a fait
une mauvaise politique elle a poursuivi
l a même accentué le laxisme d'état
ce que je regrette mais elle ya ajouté
un trait supplémentaires qui tient
peut-être à sa personnalité
un sectarisme extrêmement agressif
violent brutal vis-à-vis de l'opposition
démocratique en l'occurrence les
patriotes que nous sommes vous avez déjà
eu des mots vous même personnellement
antirépublicain vous avez une moi-même
web peut-être la fin du qatar où vous
entendu tout à l'heure oui il a signé
c'est vrai qu'elle a signé la demande de
levée d'immunité n'était pas obligé me
fera dire au delà de ça elle a eu des
propos qui n'est pas que ça elle avait
c'est ainsi que c'est une grande secteur
madame taubira est très sec tu as ça te
gêne pas je crois beaucoup plus à sa
propre personne que ne l'imaginent à ses
fans qui voient en elle une autorité
morale unis vont alors je pense que par
exemple ces deux derniers mois les a
occupés à faire du marketing et non pas
à diriger son ministère puisque elle
préparait son livre en cachette
elle préparait son coup de com elles
préparées cette petite balade en vélo
etc
kita ça s'appelle être imprésario de sa
propre personne ça ça s'appelle pas être
mise
justin oise il fallait démissionner le
23 décembre on passe au fond la cdu font
ça d'accord le cri d'alarmé de hauts
magistrats qui s'alarment que l'autorité
judiciaire soit affaiblie par le projet
notamment le projet de déchéance
selon vous la justice aujourd'hui est
elle encore la gardienne des libertés
publiques
bell douala est relais en grande partie
heureusement bien sûr pas déconsidérer
l'ensemble de l'institution et les
autorités judiciaires simplement d'abord
il y a des problèmes de moyens
indéniablement il suffit de regarder nos
moyens par rapport par habitant par
rapport à nos partenaires
on voit bien qu'on n'est pas au niveau
ça ça pose des problèmes ensuite il ya
eu vraiment une idéologie très fort de
laxisme d'explication psychologique de
lac de la criminalité de la délinquance
qui est juste pas acceptable la justice
elle est là pour juger et elle est pas
là pour psychologiser ça ça a été une
tendance qui a été défavorable aux
victimes et je le regrette profondément
et puis nous influence politique et ça
c'est totalement l'inversé sur le
deuxième point parce que 100 aubert
ajustements dans son livre notamment
elle dit qu'il faut avoir recours aux
outils sociologique pour comprendre par
exemple les jeunes français qui partent
pour le jihad et on sait qu'elles se
posent sur ce point à manuel valls 5
estime qu'il faut arrêter de trouver des
excuses
andré que de trouver des raisons c'est
trouver des excuses dit-il vous êtes
plutôt donc sur la ligne de manuel valls
que l'université que les chercheurs
cherchent bien sûr moi je suis très
favorable à la sociologie à tout le
reste
mais quand on est ministre la justice on
a une autre casquette quand on est juge
on est là pour dire la loi et pour
l'appliquer sans faiblesse en comprenant
tout mais sans faiblesse
et c'est cela qui n'est pas fait mais ça
n'a pas le même taux dire à sa date de
bien avant cette espèce de renversement
on avait le sentiment parfois qu'on
était plus proche du délinquant du
criminel que de la victime est
insupportable un projet pas le mur des
cons du syndicat de la magistrature où
il y avait des têtes de parents de
victimes assassinées considéré comme
convoyer et pas les bourreaux bonjour
d'hier sacha d'urgence je reviens sur
les régions l'état d'urgence vous vous
êtes favorable cette prolongation d'état
d'urgence moitié personnage conscience
et de la com ça sert à faire
je considère que c'est la communication
est qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
communication de monsieur hollande et de
monsieur valls qu' il n'y a aucune
mesure de fond qui n'est prise jeudi
rétablissement des frontières nationales
c'est terminé permettre au crédit de
toujours aller là où on ne pouvait pas
aller jusqu'à présent non mais
restitution réel des effectifs de police
de gendarmerie de douanes d'armes et
s'est pas fait dissolution des centaines
de mosquées radical identifiés par
ministère de l'intérieur ça n'est pas
fait voyez des vraies mesures lutter
contre le communautarisme dans les
quartiers réaffirmé la laïcité par tous
quelqu'un est arrivé souvent le terreau
de l'islamisme radical ce n'est pas fait
sécher par le reste ce n'est pas fait
pour soi ce n'est pas fait pas pas
crever nos forces de l'ordre qu'il faut
quand même aller leur parler pour voir
dans quel état elle se trouve aussi on
n'a pas intérêt non plus à aller aller
aller à tirer sur la corde de trop parce
qu'elles ne sont pas si nombreuses que
cela et parce qu'on leur demande
beaucoup beaucoup
il faudrait pas que l'état d'urgence
deviennent vigipirate vigipirate on l'a
instaurée ça devait être exceptionnelle
c'était exceptionnel
on l'a instaurée en 95 mais on n'est
jamais sorti l'état d'urgence ça doit
être exceptionnelle parce que si nous en
sommes d'ailleurs et c'était l'essentiel
voyez comment sortir aujourd'hui
affaiblie aujourd'hui on peut rester ou
sorties banon met à imaginer on vous
demande de trancher
moi je serai parlementaire je voterai
contre et quand manuel doute ferons un
autre choix comme manuel valls dit que
c'est nécessaire jusqu'à ce que la
menace tech soit fini ça leur il a tort
mais ça alors ça c'est assez inquiétant
ça veut dire que ça peut durer des
années et des années
quand est-ce qu'on décidera que la
menace est terminée et puis est-ce qui
aura pas une autre forme d'organisations
islamistes qui prendra le relais de
neige puisque on sait qu'avant dèche
toute façon ça n'a pas disparu mais il
ya eu al qaïda qui était la menace
principale et c'est à ça c'est pas un
critère tiens on ne peut pas vivre dans
ces conditions là et surtout surtout les
français sont prêts à des efforts mais
il faut que il est le sentiment qui a
une efficacité à côté si les grandes
mesures structurelles de sécurisation du
territoire ne sont pas là je parle des
frontières je parle des effectifs parle
de la lutte contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste
alors on a le sentiment de plus en plus
d'être dans la communication est ce
qu'on est dans un état policier
non on n'est pas dans un état policier
on peut pas dire ça on est dans un état
surtout inefficace vous parlez de
communicative karkwa qui parfois ne
respecte plus les libertés individuelles
ça c'est par exemple le problème de la
loire enseignement où on peut capter vos
conversations vos téléphones vos mails
sans aucune autorisation justement là
c'est un look gouvernement veut aller
plus loin beaucoup plus loin en portant
sur ce mal a notamment par exemple se
saisir des données des ordinateurs
donnant plus de pouvoirs aux policiers
précisément c'est qu'on a à la fois et
en même temps moins de liberté et moins
de sécurité voyez sécurité liberté c'est
un vieux dilemme philosophique c'est
souvent d'ailleurs un sujet ça revient à
1 périodiquement un sujet de bac philo
est ce qu'on peut concilier sécurité et
liberté bon on a plus de liberté mais
moins de sécurité et inversement
notre gouvernement et les précédents
d'ailleurs ont trouvé la clé de ses
moins de sécurité et moins de liberté
donc on est perdant perdant
et bien moi je considère qu'il ya pas
d'antagonisme entre les deux on peut à
la fois avoir plus de liberté et plus de
sécurité à condition de 30 des mesures
efficaces et souvent d'ailleurs la
sécurité rétablie la liberté puisque
quand vous êtes vous vous sentez sur
dans votre quartier
alors vous osé sortir de chez vous dans
la tenue dans laquelle vous souhaitez
être je parle des femmes notamment
vous pouvez avoir le comportement que
vous voulez vous pouvez avoir les moeurs
et la vie que vous voulez et vous
retrouver la liberté
parce qu'on vous a assuré la sécurité à
côté on va parler de la déchéance de
nationalité
est-ce que vous à titre personnel vous
soyez pour une des chances à tous les
français ça pose la question des
apatrides qui est une question
compliquée à venir voilà je pense que
c'est déjà bien de faire cette mesure là
pour les binationaux qui ne soit pas
inscrite millions si le gouvernement me
propose un statut des apatrides et qui
me paraît convaincant on peut alors y
réfléchir vraiment j'ai pas de
d'opposition de principe mais mais déjà
les binationaux ce ça me paraît plus
simple plus rapide et presque aussi
efficace vous avez vu que tout a l'air
beaucoup plus compliqué aujourd'hui il
ya eu pas mal de désaccord notamment au
sein du parti socialiste qui demande une
réécriture et qu'on enlève cette mention
des binationaux à votre avis selon vous
aujourd'hui le texte n'a pas de majorité
est ce qu'il est voué à l'échec
d'abord l'argument de certains qui
considèrent que les binationaux très
stigmatisés par cet article je ne tiens
pas la route
aucun binational ne se sente stigmatisé
tout simplement certains le disent mais
non tout simplement ce sont des
idéologues qui disent tout simplement
parce que heureusement aucun binational
ou quasiment pas heureusement non
visage de faire des attentats en france
personne ne se sent concerné par cela
ça touche ce qu'on fait des attentats
pire donc mais cette cargaison des
apatrides si jamais cet argument c'est
l'idéologie
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça fait des
semaines ou des mois maintenant qu'on
est sur ce sujet qui est d'une
simplicité biblique qui est approuvé les
grandes grande grande partie des
français mais visiblement on trouve pas
il ne crée pas de débat dans la société
française qui créent des débats parmi
des débats colloques débats ce qu'il
faut faire une différence entre ce que
karl olive elle ou pas de nationalité
c'est la question c'est un c'est un
débat de cocktail de salon ou de houe
d'assemblée dans le dans le plus décoré
sonné de la république mais ce n'est pas
un débat public jaillir les français
pour eux il n'y a pas de sujet on le
fait c'est tout et c'est d'ailleurs une
toute petite mesure par rapport à ce
qu'il faut prendre à côté pour encore
une fois assurer la sécurité des
français on en a parlé juste avant
l'agression aller plus loin ce que ce
texte vouée à l'échec
mais il ne doit pas être vouée à l'échec
le président puis s'est engagé devant le
congrès je crois le 15 novembre où le 16
novembre
est ce que ce serait une catastrophe
alors qu'on parle de mesures symboliques
ce serait ça démontrerait que le
président à un public est l'otage une
toute petite minorité d'idéologues
déconnecté des français ce serait
effectivement extrêmement peu rassurant
pour nos compatriotes et qui a raison de
la sécurité de la fermeté des autorités
que répondez-vous par exemple alain
juppé qui aujourd'hui est en déplacement
à alger et qui juge ce texte
complètement inutiles pour combattre le
terrorisme et ont sans le soutien des
députés notamment les républicains de
plus en plus hésitants mais que
répondez-vous à vue parce que plus ça
traîne plus on va être dans la politique
politicienne
sire que juppé va penser à ces primaires
va penser mais bien sûr les lecteurs en
interne et vas-y repris ce que je dois
dire pour essayer de parler d'être
repris donc on va rentrer dans la
politique politicienne qui est pas au
niveau et on a connu quand même 130
morts le 13 novembre il ya eu les
attentats de charlie avant et de l'hyper
cacher on est bien il faut prendre ce
sujet sérieusement il s'agit pas de
faire de la politique politicienne
donc nous on l'a dit si le principe lié
déchéance de nationalité qui est un
principe que effectivement on porte et
qu'on a porté seul pendant longtemps
eh bien on le votera parce que nous
auront été les grands inspirateurs de sa
cellule et gros aspirateur pas de la
déchéance de nationalité devrait vous
prenez les débats y avait personne
autour de la table à part nous pour en
parler les républicains y diffuser ni
vous soyez parce que sarkozy en a parlé
dans un discours à grenoble en juillet
2010 est donc et ne l'a jamais fait sauf
qu'il était président de la république
et qu'il lui restait encore deux ans
pour le faire ce qui prouve bien que
sarkozy et l'ump en général c'est
paroles paroles mais peu d'actions joue
peu de concrétisation encore une
question sur la dégelée hongrois c'est
une des toutes petites mesures ou alors
il faudrait l'étendre en amont de la
réalisation des attentats se serait déjà
plus efficace pour ceux qui vont
s'entraîner une de vos prêts en syrie en
irak wire au jihad pour tuer en france
et qui sont convaincus par la justice de
faire cela alors une déchéance de
nationalité et qui précédera une
expulsion du territoire national ce
serait une excellente chose je vous
somme est une phrase du livre de
christiane taubira que peut-être vous
allez lire qui s'appelle murmure à la
jeunesse vous me direz lire ou pas à
propos du terrorisme de la déchéance
elle revient à céder à la coulée
d'angoise qui signe la fin du politique
et de la politique
quelque part elle vous vise quand même
un petit peu c'est ça c'est du taubira
c'est davantage de l'an du du mauvais
poème que de la réflexion politique
revient à céder une coulée d'angoissé
vrai quelque part au sénat langois son
nom vous avez l'impression l'avant vous
savez il s'est passé ce qui s'est passé
en france en 2015 et vous pouvez pas en
vouloir aux français d'être angoissé
devant cette situation parce
qu'objectivement il n'y a pas grand
chose pour les rassurer car il s'agit
pas de vivre dans la peur mais on ne
peut pas reprocher aux français de
considérer qu'ils ne sont pas tout à
fait en sécurité en france qu'il s'est
passé des choses abominables terrible
qui touche quand même beaucoup de monde
et on attend maintenant des réponses on
n'attend pas ce genre de phrases des
réponses concrètes j'en écris ces
quelques unes
voyez par exemple avoir quitté la
belgique la france et la belgique
veulent coopérer sur le terrorisme jeudi
la meilleure des coopérations se serait
de remettre une frontière pas une
fermeture à une frontière un filtre
entre la france et la belgique la grèce
à ce serait la vraie coopération
efficace mais c'est la seule qui ne font
pas la question qui n'est pas sur la
déchéance cette fois vous promets
l'union des organisations islamiques de
france se réunissent à lille dimanche
certains orateurs sont dénoncées par les
opposants du fief réputé proche des
frères musulmans
la vigilance promise par le ministre de
l'intérieur était suffisant pour non non
ce n'est pas le premier spa première
fois d'ailleurs qu'on a ce genre de
problème avec des congrès de l'udf avec
des personnages absolument pas
recommandable c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire je crois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
promet la peine de mort pour les
homosexuels c'est ça qui est invité
il faut pas autoriser cette
manifestation vous demander son
interdiction
non mais nous on demande bien sûr que
cette manifestation soit pas autorisée
qu'on n'entende pas surtout maintenant
ce genre de propos haineux et
insupportable et qu'il y ait une
dissolution du wef
ça fait des années qu on la réclame
cette dissolution de l'unef qui sont
liées aux frères musulmans qu une
censure préalable le ministre
l'intérieur s'est refusé dit on va
regarder ce qui se passe là bas on va
dans d'autres cas il a été beaucoup plus
rapide et et s'est posé moins de
questions alors que là il me semble
qu'il ya quelque chose de même de
gravissime qui entraîne la réduction
mais oui mais bien sûr vous allez c'est
pas ce genre de propos qui va faire
avancer le débat
rien fait pour vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure à l'opposition du front national
à la récente loi sur le renseignement
dans pour laquelle s'était beaucoup
impliqué on s'en souvient jean-jacques
urvoas qui est devenu ministre de la
justice à la place de christiane taubira
un commentaire sur lui oui vous avez
bien mieux que sa prédécesseure je suis
heureux du départ de mam taubira mais ça
règle pas grand chose et nous
regarderons avec vigilance si monsieur
re as respecte les libertés
individuelles des libertés publiques
parce qu'il n'est pas manifestement un
grand ami des libertés d'après ce qu'il
a fait ce qu'il a fait voter
donc on sera vigilant bien sûr merci
michael troisième partie de preuves par
3 avec guillaume daudin de la fp
troisième question donc le front
national va-t-il changer de ligne
économique c'est sur quoi pourrait
déboucher dit on le séminaire qui va se
tenir à huis clos d'ailleurs le week-end
prochain
un ajustement rendu nécessaire
apparemment par l'absence de victoire
aux dernières élections 1 malgré un
score à 40 %
écoutez l'analyse du politologue pascal
perrineau rencontrer tout à l'heure par
contre un calme et le front national
rentrer dans une nerfs qui ait l'air de
la préparation de l'élection
présidentielle il veut mettre toutes les
chances de son côté parce qu'il
s'aperçoit qu'il y a encore un plafond
de verre sa progression on l'a très bien
vu au second tour des départementales on
l'a très bien vu au second tour des
régionales
et on le voit à la fois sur des enjeux
culturel jadis le mariage dit pour tous
on le voit aujourd'hui sur
l'appréciation du féminisme
on le voit sur des dossiers européens et
en particulier sur la question de l'euro
on le voit également sur les prises de
positions économiques et sociales on
voit bien qu'il ya parfois et bien
plusieurs front national il ya un front
national
plus au nord pas de calais picardie avec
une base très populaire qui parfois se
retrouvent dans des positions
ben oui que le front national peut
partager avec la gauche et parfois la
gauche de la gauche
et puis il ya un front national plus
bourgeois plus classe moyenne qui est
celui de provence alpes côte d'azur par
exemple et qui est sur des positions et
qui sont des positions et bien moins
étatiste moins orienté vers le poids de
la puissance publique dans l'économie
il ya différentes sensibilités ce
séminaire va avoir certainement pour
objectif si c'est possible de parler
d'une seule voix sur ces thèmes où
parfois on entend plus sûr voir voilà la
recherche d'une seule voix donc au front
national quand soir guillaume naudi donc
vous serez partir de vendredi à ce
second séminaire qui va durer jusqu'à
dimanche croit que c'est en essonne à
etiolles c'est ça c'est ça j'ai c'est
bien ça ya un ordre du jour défini pour
ce séminaire alors la thématique sait
comment préparer l'arrivée au pouvoir
puisque nous sortons d'élections où
j'entends ce qui a été dit mais malgré
tout il faut rappeler qu on a battu
notre record en pourcentage et en nombre
de voix historique mais nous sommes en
progression constante le seul parti en
dynamique dans la vie politique
française
aujourd'hui donc l'idée c'est de comment
faire mieux comment faire mieux
et pour arriver préparer cette accession
au pouvoir et après ou une organisation
des quelques demi-journées il ya une
audition au cid de personnalités qui
sont des compagnons route et dont on
aimerait avoir la vie l'opinion d'accord
donc ça on va y venir vous dit on
on va préparer l'arrivée au pouvoir du
coup on comprend pas très bien est ce
que c'est pour préparer l'arrivée au
pouvoir c'est à dire l'attrait mai 2017
si vous arriviez au pouvoir ou est-ce
que c'est comment faire en sorte
d'accéder à l'elysée
non non c'est pour préparer s'ils
voulaient cette période 2016 2017
marine le pen a fait le choix d'une
année sur le terrain rencontre des
français prendre son temps par des
déplacements à toute vitesse mais
vraiment vous l'avons la vérité d'un
fessionnels rien mais vouloir gérer
régulièrement et puis surtout je pense
qu'elle veut s'échapper du buzz parisien
médiatique lerman en quarts tire vers le
bas je crois le débat chez nous c'est
pour nous on vous dit ça vous vous êtes
une émission on a le temps on parle du
fond donc je sais pas vous que du tout
quand on visera un 1er mai mais pour le
coup parfois il ya voilà on est la
politique on n'est pas cela la politique
c'est aussi d'aller voir les médias et
les professionnels c'est parce qu'on a
on a parlé il viendra en 2017 est allé à
une conduite extrêmement sérieuse tout
le monde le sait pour la présidence de
la république
avec maintenant plus sérieuse d'ailleurs
convié le lavandou régentait séminaire
on a dit que c'était la remise en cause
des thèses que vous vous avez imposé au
front national notamment
moi je suis là ce séminaire moi je serai
direct sur le nom positif que le fonds
puisse débattre de lui assure faire son
introspection et vendredi vous allez
vous allez pas changer radicalement de
vendredi à dimanche midi il n'a pas y
avoir de changement radical vous n'allez
pas passer de la sortie de l'euro à
l'euro c'est formidable jeune ambitieuse
lancée par un séminaire programmatique
c'est un séminaire de stratégie de
discussions de débats
c'est plus sur la communication que sur
le fond en fait le front national c'est
un parti qui défend quelques grands
principes mais qui seront évidemment
intangible et qui nous différencie du
reste de la classe politique française
nous sommes pour la souveraineté
nationale donc la démocratie un jeu
c'est la même chose
nous sommes pour le l'identité nationale
et et nous considérons que la france la
nation est un modèle extrêmement
performant pour assurer la prospérité la
sécurité et la liberté
voilà ce que nous disons à partir de là
tout découle et découle de cela un monde
vraiment cohérent bas l'euro c'est la
souveraineté économique c'est la
souveraineté monétaire c'est ce qui nous
rend immédiatement la compétitivité par
rapport à l'allemagne d'avoir une
monnaie nationale
c'est ce qui permet de financer les pme
qui souffrent aujourd'hui d'un déficit
de financement bancaire extrêmement
important d'avoir comme l'immense
majorité des pays du monde mais la boule
95 de révolte et les arguments d'abord
immobilisé pour convaincre certains des
votants mais c'est l'alsace et le projet
sur l'ailé
je présente les convainc tout le monde
est souverainiste et patriotes au front
national après le conte sorte moi
j'entends parfois le projet économique
il est jean temps il ya les étatistes
les libéraux non ça c'est de l'idéologie
il est pragmatique je vous résume en une
phrase c'est la liberté d'entreprendre
avec une intervention de l'état
suffisamment forte pour effectivement
orienter des filières industrielles
organiser une réindustrialisation
innovantes et permettre et bien le
développement de l'emploi voilà ce que
nous disons vous auriez été là en 2012
auriez dit programme économique du front
c'est la sortie de l'euro pour retrouver
les libertés les pouvoirs de la france
et pouvoir essayer de rétablir
l'économie vous auriez fait de ce point
là le point central nommé c'est un point
extrêmement important sans monnaie tous
ceux qui vous disent regardez
l'expérience series à tous ceux qui vous
disent on va tout changer sans rien
changer notamment sans changer la
question de l'euro que sont les menteurs
on peut pas sortir de l'austérité c'est
à dire la baisse des salaires la baisse
des retraites
la disparition des services publics la
hausse des taxes la hausse des charges
le sens liberté monétaire donc ils sont
monnaies nationales
mais il n'ya pas que cela il ya le
protectionnisme intelligent il ya le
patriotisme économique moi je voudrais
une loi qui favorise nos petites
entreprises dans les marchés publics
comme cela existe aux états unis ou au
canada mais c'est interdit par l'union
peine et à côté cela d'un comment on
fait pour réduire les délais de paiement
pour les pme qui en souffrent comment on
fait pour l'épreuve de trésorerie pour
leurs charges etc
eh bien on a besoin de se relancer cette
activité économique
il ya ces points je vous aurais dit la
même chose mais c'est bien à la limite
c'est pas mal ce débat parce que ça
permet de remettre les points sur les i
et ceux qui découvrent aujourd'hui que
nous avons un projet économique est
beaucoup plus globale que ce qu'on a pu
croire manière caricaturale
c'est plutôt une bonne chose il ya ce
point donc programmatique et puis aussi
des points un peu d'image sondage après
sondage marine le pen reste la
personnalité au classement au palmarès
des personnalités les plus rejetée par
les français elle est constamment en
tête parfois ex-aequo récemment avec
nicolas sarkozy mais constamment en tête
est ce qu'il ya un travail à faire là
dessus pour que vous puissiez dépasser
les 50%
elle est alors en même temps en
parallèle souvent beaucoup de bonnes
opinions
oui mais est là
à 50% en corner mais le front est
victime plus que d'autres mouvements
je pars voulait venir vous jouer les
victimes non je vais te regarder la
télévision ou lire les journaux
plus que d'autres mouvements d'une
diabolisation d'une caricature de ses
thèses
ar il faut lutter contre cela moi je
pense qu'un des grands enjeux
effectivement du second tour les second
tour pourquoi il ya des gens qui se
mobilisent contre nous au second tour
qui se lèvent le matin le dimanche du
second tout en disant je vais aller
voter contre le front national
mais moi je les crois de bonne foi façon
dont on a tous déjà rencontré beaucoup à
vous les comprenez je peux parfois les
comprends parce que parce qu'ils croient
des choses qui moi aussi m'inquièterais
si elles étaient vraies sauf qu'elles
sont pas vraies elles ne sont pas vraies
il croire et ces personnes peuvent
croire par exemple que nous allons créer
du conflit d'attention de la guerre
civile comme a dit manuel valls dans la
société française or moi j'affirme et je
le démontre que nous sommes un facteur
de pacification et d'apaisement dans la
société française parce que nous on ne
fait pas de distinction entre les
français
en mai le contre le communautarisme et
cela le l'antidote au communautarisme
c'est évidemment la paix civile
de la même manière on est contre le
laxisme et le lac simon sait où ça mène
ça mène à ce que les gens se fassent
justice eux-mêmes et ça c'est le début
de la guerre civile
donc quand on est pour l'autorité contre
le laxisme on est pour la pacification
sans logis les français et ce que les
gens d'origine a qui pensent qu'on va
réduire leur liberté voilà ils ont des
idées fausses en tête je les trouvais
que la loi sur le renseignement et ce
n'était pas forcément une position
facile qu'on a eu et pourtant on a tenu
bon au nom des libertés individuelles et
nous sommes extrêmement favorable à
défendre les libertés de chacun et
chacune qui sont menacés mais par
différentes causes quand marine le pen a
pris la parole sur les femmes agressées
à cologne elle s'est battue pour les
droits des séries de nouveaux éléments
ci matinée vous l'homme c'est un sujet
important de nouveaux thèmes de 2016
l'ajustement la seule la france apaisée
c'est ce qu'il ya sur vos affiches
fin décembre il ya eu une controverse
avec rmc elle a fait des tweets ou l
comment dire ll
tout est des images de victimes de des
110 ans le dhc ça voilà horrible l'image
de décapitation relevant de la
propagande de voilà je crois qu'elle
s'en mord les doigts
elle a été vivement pour débuter pour ça
et parfois même au sein du front
national c'était quelque chose qu'il
faut arié arrêté en 2016 ce qu'il
fallait arrêter surtout c'était l'infâme
comparaison qui était faite entre le
front national et donc ses électeurs
qu'on ne joue pas ce couloir de trith ne
cadrait pas avec l'idée de l'évier 10
ans apaiser le mot d'ordre ce qui est
extrêmement choquant c'est qu'on entende
sur une grande antenne et m'a d'ailleurs
ça commençait à tout bruit courait bon
front national égale dahesh électeurs du
front égale djihadistes mais c'est juste
un juge opportunes gilles kepel défend
une thèse plus subtiles nuances et on
parle de communauté d'esprit c'est tout
cela s'appelle de l'amalgamé et je crois
que nous devons tous lutter contre les
amalgames
le padd amalgame c'est un grand le
slogan 2015 et doit s'adapter et
s'applique à tout le monde donc mais
donc ça a été efficace je constate
l'efficacité de ce café my bones à lui a
pas fait plaisir bien sûr mais il se
trouve pas non plus à celle ci se trouve
que je n'entende plus cette comparaison
depuis qu'elle l'a fait ce qui prouve
l'efficacité
alors oui ça a été très très dommageable
aussi pour pour la perception qu'ont les
français je pense que ce bruit insidieux
était infiniment plus dommageable au
front national et surtout à la dignité
de nos électeurs donc pour élargir les
donc la réalié d'atteindre les 50% vous
avez séminaire ce week-end et il y aura
vous avez dit l'audition de
personnalités amies donc tu auras robert
ménard c'est ça qui sera qui sera là ce
week-end est ce que free ne voulait pas
des tensions dans sa ville mais
semble-t-il quand même vous dites la
france apaisée mais ce monsieur ménard
on sent qu'il ya beaucoup de tension
enfin le nom il ya souvent des noms non
il ya des polémiques on essaie de créer
depuis paris dans sa ville il est
plébiscité par les élections
intermédiaires très massivement il a
baissé je crois qu'il arrive au niveau
de fiscalité de 1995 d'accord d'accord
mais rayonnants moulin je crois que
c'est même lui qui a fait à paris au
grade de la république sur son
initiative qui prouve notre local voilà
il est levé
le bouclier de personnes diverses et
assure chaque ville ça on vous avez la
petite association de 7 8 personnes qui
trouvera des relais très facilement dans
les médias l'idée d'une garantie barouf
son petit bruit à chaque fois que le
front prend une décision mais je trouve
moi je vous savez le seul critère qui
m'intéresse c'est pas les rédactions de
presse parisienne c'est pas la petite
association de 5,6 militants là sur
glace est fait c'est le vote des
électeurs et je trouve que le vote il
est massivement derrière lui et il est
massivement derrière nos mères dans
l'ensemble des communes d'ailleurs si on
progresse d'élections médicales locales
qui par exemple a retoqué son idée d'une
garde biterroise en disant que ça
correspondait pas forcé gtc son projet
je ne sais pas si moi je l'aurais fait
mais c'est son projet de gens
volontaires non armés
ça a rien d'extraordinaire donc celle en
voyant que c'est une décision politique
robert ménard sera là ce week-end
philippe de villiers sera là où il a
écrit après une annonce va presser pas
prévu il ferait partie des personnes que
vous souhaiteriez voir rejoindre le
front national
enfin houleux le grand rassemblement d'à
et philippe de villiers moi j'ai cru
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui il était
écrivain part il a une voix qui est
intéressante il a intervient dans le
débat par ce biais et c'est ce qu'il
semble avoir dit moi je ne souhaite pas
faire de politique
après ce qu'il souhaitera en faire plus
tard je n'en sais strictement rien il a
eu le courage en tout cas de ses
convictions pendant des années des
années qu'ils sont toujours les mêmes
évidemment notamment son grand combat
contre la supranationalité contre
maastricht et en cela il a été une
grande voix des années 90 il ya donc
philippe de villiers pour l'instant n'a
pas l'air d'être voilà d'être de vouloir
s'allier à vous nicolas dupont aignan
l'église n'est pas là pour faire de la
politique je crois il
il laisse entendre que peut-être il
pourrait revenir nicolas ducron erhard
exclu chevénement l'a toujours exclu le
ps et les républicains on n'en parle pas
vous pensé quand même pouvoir bien mais
pas demandeur je 1017 le fait c'est la
musica on n'ait pas demandé au modem on
dit c'est la crise et la part des petits
partis qui gravitent dans la galaxie du
front national vous savez faisable on
progresse on progresse on progresse la
question c'est eux qui sont obligés de
s'allier et même de faire alliance ump
est non mais ils sont obligés de faire
ça ils sont acculés à cela pour espérer
l'emporter on l'a vu aux régionales ter
dans deux régions et nîmes et
continuer à perdre et ça c'est un regret
attend les accule à soit renoncer à
avoir des élus ce qui est quand même
particulier la conception du ps
aujourd'hui elle est particulière c'est
un parti politique qui renonce à avoir
des élus qui renonce à se présenter aux
élections
c'est tout à fait particulier mais il
s'agit d'un prix coup de main elle
n'avait pas répondu à la question
combien on est loin vous savez très bien
qu'on on a des cadres le court nahd et
des personnalités locales qui arrivent
tous les jours quasiment on vient vous
le sait pas forcément des têtes
d'affiché vous connaissez mais est ce
que c'est ce qu'on vit en amont
parlement de discussion avec le centre
nous avons dit nous avons des collectifs
sociaux professionnels qui chaque jour
font venir des nouveaux profils des
chefs d'entreprise des universitaires
des chercheurs des médecins gère ça
c'est intéressant des avocats nous avons
une capacité de l'attraction extrêmement
fort dans la population française
on tend la main à tous les patriotes de
gauche et de droite on a tendu la main
moi j'ai tendu la main je ne sais
combien de fois un monsieur
dupont-aignan
oui sauf moi j'ai fini ce rassemblement
devrait venir parce que j'ai fini par
comprendre qu'il voulait à tout prix
être candidat à la présidentielle en
et donc il ne pourrait rien faire il est
dans une aventure personnelle
ben je vous le dis je le regrette je
vous le dis très clairement je le
regrette profondément parce que je pense
que l'union des patriotes est absolument
alors indice que le front national doit
changer de nom tout simplement pour se
débarrasser de l'image que vous évoquez
vous dis qu'on vous fait des procès
d'intention
faut-il changer de nom besoins en orge
et ont essayé de changer de nom je n'ai
pas d'opinion mais pas d'opinion sur l
autre on en discutera prof doit
devra-t-elle quitté la piscine à des
sujets premier bon est-ce que marine le
pen devrait quitter la présidence du
front national lors de la campagne
est ce que cette partie des options dont
vous les suspects les options oui ou non
on peut discuter de tout il est évident
qu'elle n'est plus
j'écoutais les cantons des candidats à
la présidentielle petit et c'est la
personnalité avant le parti après ce
qu'elle doit quitter ou pas les
réussites et les incidences sur la table
est resté président du mouvement 2012
cela posé de problème à personne mais
les toutes dernières questions sur la
grande bretagne sais pas si c'est un
modèle pour vous en tous les cas je ne
parle pas du bric site mais des négos
13,6 brille mais je parle des
négociations pour l'éviter du règlement
avec davitamon qui est qui qui négocie à
bruxelles des aménagements sur la
souveraineté
oui mais je pense que monsieur cameron
en fait il fait ce gouvernement
européiste qui fait ce référendum contre
1 parce qu'il ya une forte demande
royaume uni et alors que nous nous
proposons ce référendum aussi sur
l'appartenance à l'union européenne
précédé de négociations mais nous
serions un gouvernent
demande patriotes qui ferait
volontairement ce référendum était tout
à fait différent donc mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'on sait également des
entretiens de fausses négociations pour
éviter à tout prix que les britanniques
votent le bras exit la sortie lui niant
de l'union européenne et bien moi
j'espère qu'ils voteront la sortie de
l'union européenne parce que il n'a
obtenu que de très maigres vous avancez
monsieur cameron aujourd'hui est donc et
donc il ne peut pas présenter cela comme
une avancée majeure
j'encourage nos amis patriotes
britannique a voté la sortie de l'union
européenne et j'espère que nous aurons
nous aussi notre france exit où notre
exil je sais pas comment on doit dire
c'était un référendum en france sur
cette question majeure démocratiques
politiques et que l'avenir sécurité
régis et l'union rotation ne montre pas
que finalement le seul moyen pour vous
de faire ce que voulait faire c'est de
sortir l'union européenne que c'est le
chemin auquel vous devrait aboutir
quand les négociations sont sincères par
un gouvernement déterminé
elles peuvent peut-être aboutir et si
elles n'aboutissent pas si la machine
est effectivement irréformable alors on
fera le choix de la sortie merci merci à
vous messieurs bonsoir à tous et à très
vite merci
qui